Ok, das war es viel zu früh, ich bin exakt, naja gut nicht exakt,
aber quasi um 10 am start, aber ich muss mal kurz gucken ob lautstärke und so alles passt, weil ich habe ja, ja passt passt alles gut, ich habe ein bisschen rumgestellt für letzten stream, ist aber eigentlich alles passt, exellent.
So, auf gehts, ich habe jetzt schon Hunger Leute, ich habe gerade zwei Brötchen gefordert, ich könnte jetzt Mittagessen, ich habe jetzt schon Hunger, weiß auch nicht warum die irgendwie einfach nur durchgelaufen sind, oben reingeschoben Brötchen und irgendwie nichts angekommen.
Aber das liegt wahrscheinlich daran, ich habe letzte Woche Asia bestellt und ich habe noch komplette Portion Futter, also komplette Portion Mittagessen da und das Zeug schmeckt von dem Asia Laden immer ganz gut, deswegen will ich wahrscheinlich den Kram jetzt direkt Pepo Fett wegfuddern, genau.
Also immer eine Erfahrung von euch mit Azure Functions, klappt mir jetzt nicht wie ich draufkomme.
Ich muss nämlich nächste Woche was programmieren mit Azure, also in Azure Functions, habe ich sonst noch nie gemacht, mal gucken.
Und wie lief euer Turnier gestern, ich habe nicht reingeguckt, ich habe nur deinen Twitter Post gesehen, dass ihr heute irgendwie spielt.
Eifert ihr richtig?
By the way, ich weiß nicht ob ich die Leute heute wieder triggern soll mit Team Sounds.
17 Uhr geht es weiter, gucke ich nachher mit.
Ich glaube das lasse ich sonntags, keine Team Sounds.
Ich habe mittlerweile so viele Emotes in meinem Pepega Board, ich habe gar keine Ahnung mehr, wo was ist wenn ich suche, das ist so voll.
Bis heute habe ich es nicht auf die Reihe gekommen die Suche ordentlich zu programmieren, das Ding hat ja eigentlich eine Suche hier oben, aber die funktioniert nicht.
Wenn ich hier eingebe Aja ja, dann geht es kaputt, es fängt an zu filtern und dann...
Moment, wenn ich Ja ja eingebe geht es, warum geht es nicht wenn ich Aja...
Also ich muss nach, das ist, ne okay das geht, ich habe keine Ahnung, das ist irgendwie total broken was ich da gebaut habe.
Wann kommt die aktuellste Version davon auf Git? Die aktuellste Version ist 2,5 Jahre oder so alt, ich habe daran nichts mehr gemacht.
Weil die kommt nicht aufs JIT.
Allerdings zum Thema JIT, ich wollte eigentlich am Freitag, was mit der Endpunkt aufnehmen hat leider nicht funktioniert, sehr Premiere gewesen, dass ich mal ein Video mit dem ehemaligen Azubi von mir aufnehme.
Läuft ein Samba Server auf einer VM oder direkt auf...
Wie hast du das bei deinem großen Server gemacht?
Es ist alles direkt auf Ubuntu drauf.
Ich habe auf meiner 2 HE Kiste, die fette Kiste habe ich ja downgraded, die gibt es ja nicht immer im Einsatz, die hat ein bisschen viel Strom gefressen.
Ich habe es jetzt so, ich habe ein paar Sachen als Container mit Docker Compose file laufen und tatsächlich der Samba Server ist ein Docker Container glaube ich sogar.
Kann aber auch sein, dass er direkt auf Ubuntu drauf ist, ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Also ich habe eine Mischung aus ein paar Docker Containern und eine VM, eine VM läuft noch und das ist Home Assistant, weil es in der VM besser läuft.
Genau, so sieht es aus.
Was ist hier los? Ich habe Hunger. Schaust du morgen WWDC? Könnte man eigentlich machen ja.
Wie viel Uhr ist denn das morgen? Ich habe mir morgen frei, das passt eigentlich.
Moment Dark Reader, please, please.
Yes, excellent, excellent.
Auf der Entwickler Konferenz zeigt Apple die nächsten Betriebs... Blablabla.
Ist das schon wieder? War da nicht erst was?
Haben wir nicht erst Tim Apple zugeguckt?
7. Juni.
Ok, morgen. Wie viel Uhr?
Steht da irgendwie CST Uhr?
Ja, wie viel Uhr ist es denn morgen?
How to watch news.
Ja, 7. Juni um 19 Uhr. Das mache ich, das schreibe ich mir gleich mal in den Kalender, dass ich es nicht vergesse.
Ja, ich habe jetzt auch so einen Boomer Kalender, dass ich mir die Sache nicht vergesse.
Also sprich Eintracht machen, morgen, 7. um wann ist das? 19 Uhr?
Dann nenne ich mal Attendees, Tim Apple, alles klar.
So, starts, 19.00, dann schreibe ich jetzt einfach noch dabei, das Ding soll mal Bescheid sagen, eine Stunde vorher.
Oder zwei Stunden vorher oder so, ok.
Excellent, sehr gut.
Ok, habe ich jetzt dabei.
Ja, können wir morgen Apple Event gucken.
Aufpassen, wenn die Musik streamen, da muss man das gleich löschen, danach das What oder direkt.
Was wird denn vermutet? Predictions.
Tom's Guide, ich kenne die ganzen Seiten alle.
Ok, was wird denn prediktet?
Best iPhones right now, ja gut, das sagen sie ja zu allem.
M2 Chip, ist nicht erst der M1 rausgekommen?
Stimmt, was ist eigentlich bei der Geschichte rausgekommen mit Epic Games und Apple Store?
Habe ich gar nicht verfolgt.
Der M1 ist ein Jahr alt, ok.
Ok, das ist so ein typischer Newsartikel, wir wissen überhaupt gar nichts.
Ah ja, jetzt, ok, soft predictions.
Predictions.
Big Sur.
Ja, warten wir mal ab, wir wissen eh weder wie ein Apple Event läuft.
Die werden uns 30 Milliarden mal erzählen, dass das so amazing, so easy, thrilling, hyped, was auch immer, huge, massive, was auch immer ist.
Und sie werden coole Trailer machen, das können sie bei Apple ja immer gut.
Also diese kleinen Clips, das sind ja gar keine Trailer.
Wie nennt man das denn diese kleinen Werbeintros, die sie da immer haben, die können die echt ganz gut.
Aber ansonsten wird es wahrscheinlich total unspektakulär sein, so wie die letzten Apple Events auch.
Ich meine beim letzten Apple Event war mein persönliches Highlight, das sagt schon alles, ein komischer Bluetooth Knopf.
Und das war noch nicht mal Highlight in dem Sinne, dass ich es mir jetzt kaufen werde oder so.
BF6 Leaks wieder, oh da muss ich aufpassen, wenn ich BF6 Leaks zeige, weil ich weiß ja schon wie Battlefield 6 aussieht.
Da muss ich aufpassen, dass ich nichts verrate.
Jack Waite, da muss ich einfach Klappe halten und Level Cap und Shibane lassen.
Ich tue einfach so, als weiß ich es nicht.
Ich ignoriere einfach alles und sage nichts.
Ich finde es aber witzig, wenn man weiß wie das Game aussieht, ob man die ganzen Leak Gerüchte auf Reddit sieht,
wo es dann auf der einen Seite totale Schwachsinnensbilder gibt, wo die Leute sagen, oh nee, kann ja überhaupt nicht sein.
Und dann gibt es Bilder, wo ich halt von denen weiß, dass sie echt sind.
Und dann schreiben die Leute dabei, oh nein, es muss fake sein.
Das ist eigentlich ganz lustig.
Ja leider darf ich euch absolut gar nichts erzählen über das Game.
Grip, hast du auch so eine angebliche Nachricht von Battlefield auf Twitter bekommen?
Woher weißt du wie Battlefield 6 aussieht?
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich überhaupt etwas sagen darf, warum ich es weiß.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß es.
Ich weiß nicht, ich habe es mir nicht im Detail durchgelesen, was ich unterschrieben habe, was ich nicht sagen darf.
Darf ich überhaupt sagen, dass ich etwas unterschrieben habe, was ich nicht sagen darf?
Keine Ahnung.
Illuminati, ja.
Deswegen finde ich es auch immer lustig, wenn hier so Leute wie Levelcap oder...
Moment, wo habe ich... Ich habe doch hier so ein Battlefield-Video aufgemacht.
Deswegen finde ich es auch immer lustig, wenn gerade solche Leute da immer so tun, so nach dem Motto,
confirm? Fragezeichen? Wie? Wie? Was? Die wissen ganz genau, was Sache ist.
Du hast doch gesagt, dass du angeschrieben hast, bevor du uns unterschrieben hast. Ja, dann.
Ja, dann werde ich schon mal erzählen. Ist ja auch egal.
Ich darf zumindest keine Details erzählen.
Aber ich werde zum Reveal ein Video mit dem Lost hochladen.
So, das kann ich schon verraten.
Das muss ich mir nur noch mal absinken lassen, ob ich da nicht Dinge erzähle, die ich nicht erzählen darf.
Also, mal gucken. Mal schauen, mal schauen.
Es dauert ja nicht mehr lang. Ist ja bald.
Battlefield 6 Reveal.
Genau, neunter.
Das können wir uns zusammen angucken, übrigens.
Was ist das denn? Wann ist denn der neunte? Der neunte ist Mittwoch.
Okay.
Das können wir uns, das können wir machen. Das können wir machen.
Dann werde ich mir im Vorfeld nochmal genau erklären lassen, was ich sagen darf und was nicht.
Und dann machen wir am neunten nachmittags einen Stream, wo ich dann ein bisschen mehr erzähle zu dem Game.
Wie gesagt, also ich weiß noch einiges mehr über das Game, als das, was es dann wahrscheinlich da zu sehen gibt.
Also, ja.
Das können wir machen dann am neunten. Vorher geht das nicht.
Sieht man bei dir Gameplay im Video?
Das weiß ich noch nicht.
Kein Kommentar.
Da kann man ja quasi auf Twitch hier einen Streamplan erstellen.
Ich könnte eigentlich mit dem Lost Stream.
Mittwoch, 19 Uhr.
Du musst ihn mal fragen, das wäre eigentlich ganz gut.
Brauchst du optimistisch zu Battlefield 6? Ja.
Nee, 16 Uhr, 16 Uhr, nicht 19 Uhr, 16 Uhr ist es, ne?
Am Ende ist alles ein riesiger Bait von Max. Ja, kann sein, kann sein.
Streamkalender.
Wie viele Fraktionen wird es geben? Das habe ich nichts zu.
Keg-Wade, Alter.
Ich halte mich an sowas.
Da ist schon das andere immer irgendwelche Leaks raushauen und heimlich Sachen aufnehmen und sonst was.
So, also.
Wenn du Android nutzen würdest, was für ein Handy würdest du nehmen?
Wahrscheinlich ein offizielles Google, was kosten die Dinger?
Wie kosten, was heißen die?
Früher hießen die, die heißen Pixel jetzt, ne?
Früher hießen die ja anders. Früher hießen die doch, ähm.
Wie hießen die Dinger früher?
Die hatten auch früher, Nexus, Nexus, genau.
Wird es wieder eine Frau mit Hakenhand geben?
Ne.
Ich glaube, das kann nicht liegen, das wird es nicht geben.
Oder keine Ahnung, ich weiß es nicht.
Ich weiß es nicht, ob es das geben wird.
So, also was kosten der Kram gerade?
Also wenn ich mir ein Android-Handy holen würde, dann wahrscheinlich ein offizielles Google-Handy,
dass der Kram auch ein bisschen länger supportet wird.
Das sind aber keine Apple-Preise.
Also für Apple-Preise müsste der Kram mindestens doppelt so teuer sein.
Weißt du...
Weißt du schon, was über das neue Kort, ne?
Ich war eh überrascht, ehrlich gesagt, dass mich, ähm, EA gefragt hat, ob ich mir Battlefield 6 angucken will.
Weil, ich mach ganz im Ernst, ich hab die letzten Jahre über jetzt nicht wahnsinnig viel Battlefield-Content gebracht
und ich hab das Spiel eigentlich auch zum größten, die letzten zwei Spiele eigentlich auch zum größten Teil geflamed.
Also, ich hätte mich wahrscheinlich nicht eingeladen, aber ok.
Wichtiger Jonas sagt, hat mir vor zwei Tagen ein OnePlus 8T gekauft, jetzt auf den Boden gefallen, RIP.
Ja, zack.
Wenn man das noch fett gibt...
Warum gibt's denn da so viele?
Ja, also wenn ich mir ein Android-Handy kaufen würde, dann wahrscheinlich ein offizielles, dass ich auch weiß, dass ich Updates krieg.
Also, ich muss halt ehrlich sagen, ich bin schon seit ein paar Jahren so auf Apple-Handys hängen geblieben.
Das liegt aber auch zum größten Teil daran, weil ich von der Firma ein Apple-Handy immer gestellt kriege.
Und ich sehs dann nicht ein, noch ein eigenes Handy zu kaufen, wozu, wenn man schon eins hat.
Ich hab jetzt ein iPhone 11, das reicht mir. Ich hatte ja vorher ein XR, das XR hätte mir auch noch gereicht.
Gibt ja kaum noch Deutsche, die Battlefield-Content machen. Ja, das stimmt, aber das liegt ja einfach daran, weil die letzten Battlefield-Teile gesackt haben.
Hast du Infos zum neuen Half-Life 3? Ja. Hab ich.
Ich bin der Einzige auf der Welt, der weiß, wann Half-Life 3 rauskommt.
Half-Life 2 ist ja jetzt irgendwie Game of the Decade oder so.
Hab ich wahrscheinlich irgendwo gelesen.
Oder ist das schon?
Oder war das schon länger her?
Aber haben sie auch recht. Hätte ich wahrscheinlich auch gewählt. Wobei es gerade so 2000 bis 2010 echt viele geile Games gab.
Ja, Captain Peng ist echt so. Also wenn ich Battlefield spiele, dann spiel ich eigentlich nur noch ein paar Runden Battlefield 3.
Und dann ist gut, dann reicht es mir auch schon wieder.
Half-Life.
Wenn ich zwischen den zwei aussuchen müsste.
Genau, ich bin der einzige Entwickler von Half-Life 3. Jetzt ist es raus. Jetzt ist es raus.
Mal gucken, ob YouTube jetzt noch irgendwas Neues hat, was es uns empfiehlt.
Heute war echt nur Crap dabei in den YouTube-Empfehlungen.
Hat jemand irgendwelche guten Videos, die wir gucken müssen?
Irgendwas, was sich für den Stream eignet. Nicht irgendwelche sinnlosen Gebates.
Also YouTube hat mir heute wirklich nur Müll empfohlen.
I am Onex. Dankeschön, zwei Monate Subscription.
Ich habe übrigens die ganzen Subs nicht vorgelesen, die ich gekriegt habe hier in der Zwischenzeit.
Also nicht heute, sondern zwischen den Streams. Da waren ein paar Sachen dabei.
Der Zorix hat zum Beispiel gesubbt vor 18, ne, vor, ne, zwischen den zwei Streams, genau.
Dann habe ich für den Sub, dann haben wir Jan Wack, Headknock, der CheesyPro ist wieder am Start.
Hongas.
Das wäre lustig.
Killerspiele, die Lügen der Medien. Oh ne, ne, dieses Thema kriege ich nicht.
Das ist von 2011. Killerspiele ist.
Aber habt ihr mal gemerkt, wie schnell Killerspiele vorbei sind an Thema?
Das war ja mal, sagen wir mal so, von 2000 an bis 2015 oder so war das laufend irgendwo im Gespräch.
Und die letzten fünf Jahre gibt es einfach gar nichts mehr.
Ich glaube, das liegt zum größten Teil daran, dass Gaming jetzt einfach komplett Mainstream ist.
Mit allen seinen Vor- und Nachteilen. Hatte nicht nur Vorteile.
Und dass viele Leute selbst spielen, die jetzt da in Positionen sind, die darüber entscheiden, was da gemacht wird und was nicht.
Also Killerspiele hat sich komplett erledigt. Es gibt mal irgendwo wieder einer oder was erzählt.
Dieser komische Hirnforscher, da ist er auch immer ganz vorne mit dabei.
Weiß nicht, ob es den Pfeiffer noch gibt.
Aber ansonsten hat es mit Killerspiele eigentlich ausgekillerspielt.
Das liegt auch an Fortnite.
Ja, das kann schon durchaus sein.
Fortnite sieht halt wirklich nicht aus wie ein Killerspiel.
IWS mit einem Video zu Crowfall.
Ich glaube nicht, dass...
Was ich bei MMOs lustig finde, hat irgendjemand...
Also es gibt zwei MMOs, wo ich nicht checke, was Sache ist.
Es gibt einmal dieses Hype MMO, wo jetzt jeder was zu gesagt hat.
Ashes of Creation.
Wo ich eigentlich dachte, die sind dann und haben jetzt einen Battle Royale gemacht und haben sich verpisst.
Aber anscheinend doch nicht. Die sind da wohl noch dabei.
Und dann gab es ja dieses Chronicles of Illyria, die eigentlich auch gesagt haben, sie sind Pleite oder so.
Und danach haben irgendwie Leute gesagt, wir verklagen dich jetzt, weil du das Geld eingesagt hast und kein Game gemacht hast.
Und jetzt entwickelte er angeblich doch wieder an dem Game.
Ich blicke legit bei aktueller MMO Entwicklung nicht mehr durch.
Painschamp.
Teile deine Skills, werde Informatiklehrerin.
Okay, machen wir das, gucken wir mal, das ist nicht lang.
Oh, so krasses Dubstep Intro, Alter.
Und jetzt geht ja schon Painschamping los, Alter.
Wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp.
Dubstep ist auch out, oder?
Können euch noch dran erinnern?
Als jeder so 2012 11 rum Montage gemacht hat, war da überall wupp, wupp, wupp drinne.
Mittlerweile hat das keiner mehr.
Der 3D Kick ist doch nicht am Start, nee.
Es macht auch kaum noch einer darude Sandstorm Jokes und Memes, das ist auch vorbei.
Dubstep ist krass tot, glaube fast keine Musikrichtung ist so hart gefailed wie die.
Ich hab weder Dubstep gehört, als es angesagt war, noch jetzt.
Gut, ein paar Sachen sind natürlich auch so dem jeweiligen Zeitgeist geschuldet, ja.
Es gibt auch keine Fuss Rodar Collections mehr oder Compilations mehr.
Das war ja so zu Skyrim Zeiten, wo sie einfach dieses komische Dragonborn Intro reingeschnitten haben und dann sind Leute aufs Maul gefallen.
Ich muss ehrlich gestehen, ich fand das zur damaligen Zeit echt lustig.
So, was wird uns jetzt hier erzählt?
YouTube, was gibt's da so?
Alter, was ist das für MonkaS Musik?
Also außer, dass man sie kaum hört.
So, besser.
Schinke Kuro, dankeschön, 23 Monate, huge.
Hyper Subscriber.
Genau, Arkenas, but there is one day fear Dragonborn.
Fuss Rodar.
Das war doch sein. Ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich glaube, ich bin der Einzige, der Skyrim nicht wirklich gespielt hat.
Also ich hab's auf Steam, aber ich hab's vielleicht eine Stunde gespielt.
Ich bin da nie reingekommen. Aber was ich cool finde, ist Dings hier.
Hab ich jetzt angefangen.
Ohne Scheiß, ich hab jetzt, ich hab fünf, sechs Stunden hier schon den Mod gespielt.
Fand ich viel, find ich viel besser als das originale Skyrim.
Weiß ich, wahrscheinlich habt ihr das alle schon vor fünf Jahren oder so gespielt, als es rausgekommen ist.
Ich find das echt nice.
Ja, Morrowind war nice. Morrowind hab ich gespielt, aber das war ja noch Boomer Zeiten.
Das war Unreal, Unreal 1 Game, glaub ich. Morrowind.
Unreal Engine 1. Oder Unreal 1 Engine. Was auch immer.
Ich kann mir nicht merken, worum das heißt.
Du hast Skyrim für die Switch auch nie gespielt.
Ja, wer spielt auch Skyrim und Witcher auf der Switch?
Der Switcher. Der Switcher in 600 x 400 Auflösungen oder was auch immer das auf der Switch hat.
Na ja.
Hey Max, du hast ja Unify Access Points. Machst du dort...
Ja, mach ich, mach ich. Ja, ja, mach ich.
Mein IoT WLAN hat ein eigenes WLAN.
Und das muss man auf der einen Seite einstellen am MikroTik und auf der anderen Seite einstellen am Unify Controller.
Ist das? Ich dachte, Morrowind war Unreal. Bin ich jetzt total verwirrt?
War das Game? Da sind tatsächlich viele MMOs früher mit Game, Gameprio oder wie man das ausspricht.
War Morrowind nicht Unreal?
Bring ich das jetzt durcheinander?
Tatsächlich. Hätte ich nicht gedacht. Irgendwie habe ich im Hinterkopf, das wäre Unreal gewesen, das erste.
Äh, auch über verschiedene Assets, ID's. Ja.
Gar kein Problem.
Ja, das ist das, was sie auch für Fallout und so verwenden. Aber es gibt relativ viele alte MMOs, die da auch...
Das war wohl früher relativ beliebt hier da Kram.
Gibt es Half-Life auf der Switch? Kein Schimmer, was da die Orange Box oder so gab.
Na gut, also schauen wir mal was. Was hat YouTube denn heute zu bieten?
Ich habe übrigens ein richtiges PainsChamp-Video gefunden, Leute. Wobei wir gucken jetzt erst mal das Video an, was jemand im Chat geschert hat.
Teile deine Skills, werde Informatik-Lehrerin. Schreibt man das jetzt nicht? Schreibt man jetzt nicht korrekterweise?
Lehrer, Sternchen, Innen oder Doppelpunkt? Und dann ist die Frage, ob das i groß oder klein?
Lieber nicht. Okay, zeigt mal her.
Alter, wupp wupp wupp wupp wupp.
Das sich bei Twitch empfohlen zu bekommen, früher bei der Black Ops 1-Video. Nice, dass du hier bist.
Okay, es geht nach 28 Sekunden. Ich weiß nicht, wer das Video empfohlen hat, aber es fängt schon PainsChamp-ig an.
Werde Informatik-Lehrer. Was zum Teufel hat das mit Informatik-Lehrer zu tun? Und was ist das für wupp wupp wupp im Hintergrund?
Was genau hat das mit Informatik-Lehrer zu tun? Außerdem, der Typ ist keine Ahnung, 16 oder so, der wird bestimmt kein Informatik-Lehrer.
Also jetzt noch nicht.
What?
Okay, was ein bescheuertes. Vor allem, wie das einfach 14.000 Views hat und keiner hat kommentiert. Das liegt wahrscheinlich daran, dass sie das intern 50 Billionen mal aufgerufen haben.
Oder sogar Ads geschaltet haben auf YouTube.
Ähm, würde euch das ansprechen, Lehramt zu studieren?
Also mich nicht. Ich würde aber im Leben auch sowieso nie Lehramt studieren.
Nein, klar. Also ich würde im Leben nicht Lehramt studieren. Allein schon, wenn ich mir vorstellen müsste, ich müsste mich täglich mit irgendwelchen Kindern oder Jugendlichen auseinandersetzen.
Und dann nicht nur mit 1, 2, sondern auch noch mit 30 auf einmal.
Äh, ne, ne. Also ich meine, normale Leute gehen mir schon auf den Sack. Kinder aber erst recht.
Du würdest die Kinder einfach ins WLAN tun. Du meinst quasi, wenn man das dann mal auf Real Life überträgt, du würdest die dann quasi einsperren in der Klasse und abhauen.
Oder die Tür zwischen zwei Klassenräumen aufmachen und du gehst über den Flur. Das wäre natürlich auch eine Idee.
Ein Azubi alleine raubt einem schon die Nerven. Ne, das finde ich nicht. Das stört mich nicht. Azubis hatte ich auch schon viele.
War jetzt nicht irgendwie, dass die ein Jahr am Stück jeden Tag bei mir waren oder so, aber halt ganz normal bei uns im Team und das hat eigentlich, das fand ich immer, immer nice.
So, jetzt wissen wir, wie man in, in my homeland Baden-Württemberg, we say we are all sitting in one boat.
Das ist hier Oettinger Heimatland. Was empfehlen die mir hier noch mal in dem Video? Alter, ist ja gut. Werde eine Reli-Lehrerin?
Was ist denn eine Reli-, Religion-Lehrerin oder was ist eine Reli-Lehrerin? Ist das Religion? Ne, oder? Kannst du dir nicht vorstellen.
Was ist Reli? Echt? Warum überhaupt noch Religion? Die sollen Oetting machen und gut ist.
Das bestimmt genauso cringe wie das andere.
Und weiter. Scheint ja äußerst spannend zu sein. Man guckt den ganzen Tag sich Bücher an.
Das heißt, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du Religionslehrer wirst, setzt du dich auf den, auf die, auf die Erde in der Bibliothek und die Mädels kommen freiwillig zu dir und sagen,
Guck mal da, du bist Religionslehrer. Das finde ich aber nice.
Die Videos sind so schlecht, ja.
Was soll, ey, Alter, was soll uns das Video überhaupt sagen?
Wer ist der Schüler und sie, die sind doch ungefähr gleich alt oder ist das mein Boomer-Blick, der das nicht mehr erkennt?
Okay, ich habe ehrlich gesagt keinen Plastenschimmer, was die uns mit diesen Videos sagen wollen.
Quench-Level.
Hat da eigentlich einer kommentiert? Warum hat das 30.000? Die haben Werbe, die haben Werbezeug geschaltet auf YouTube.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass das Video sich jemand sonst freiwillig anguckt. Im Leben nicht.
Das wollen sie uns wahrscheinlich damit sagen, ja. Komplett sinnfreies Video.
Welchen Mikrotik-Router hast du? Ich brauche einen mit 4 x 10 Gigabit Ports.
Nee, habe ich nicht. Meiner hat gar keine Gigabit Ports. Meiner hat 6 Gigabit Ports, 5 Kupfer, 1 SFP-Port.
Aber wenn du einen brauchst, die haben jetzt 9. Sekunde, die haben einen 9, nicht den.
Ach, komm on. Die Mikrotik-Seite, es sackt. Die haben jetzt 9, habe ich gelesen. Ich weiß nicht, ob das schon raus ist.
Brauchst du wirklich einen Router? Brauchst du wirklich Routing-Performance?
Oder brauchst du eigentlich einen Switch, der ein bisschen Layer 3 kann?
Also im Prinzip ja, ich weiß, ihr kennt mich. Es gibt keine Layer 3-Switches. Ist im Prinzip richtig.
Das ist ein Switch, der routen kann. Ich weiß, das werden die Cisco-Leute anders sehen.
Aber für mich ist halt bei Mikrotik der Unterschied zwischen, die haben einmal Hardware, die halt eine fette CPU hat, die ordentlich Gigabit-weise routen kann.
Oder die haben einen Switch, der ein bisschen routen kann, aber halt nicht die CPU hat, besonders viel Traffic zu machen.
Das ist halt die Frage, weil die Switches sind in der Regel günstiger und du kriegst mehr Ports dafür.
Ansonsten musst du einfach mal gucken. Die hatten aber einen neuen.
Das ist ungefähr den, den ich habe in dem Dreh.
Du brauchst auf jeden Fall mehrfach SF.
Der ist tatsächlich ganz nice, das ist aber hauptsächlich ein Switch, der ein bisschen routen kann.
Der ist gut, den habe ich auch hier. Den haben wir sogar uns im Stream schon mal angeguckt.
Ist der Chat unterhalb der Katze kaputt? Nee.
Okay, dann brauchst du echt einen fetten Router. Dann musst du dir mal die Performance-Geschichten angucken.
Von den jeweiligen Sachen, das weiß ich aus dem Kopf jetzt auch nicht.
So, also, was gucken wir uns denn jetzt an?
Ach, ich wollte euch ja noch was zeigen, was richtig Paints-Champig ist.
Ähm, warte mal, wo habe ich es denn?
Ach ja, Leute, wisst ihr was ich geil finde?
Ich habe doch mal gesagt, wir können eine IHK-Zwischenprüfung im Stream machen.
Dann habe ich gesagt, geht nicht, weil die sind ja copyrighted.
Ich hätte nie gedacht, dass es auf YouTube Videos gibt, wo jemand die Fragen zeigt von der IHK-Prüfung.
Das heißt, dann kann ich mich jetzt rausreden mit, wieso, ich gucke doch nur YouTube-Videos.
Deswegen habe ich mir das mal gepuckt, das gucken wir uns aber nicht jetzt an.
Ich wollte euch was anderes zeigen. Was ist das denn hier?
Alter, dieses Video ist so hardcore cringe.
Ich will euch damit jetzt nicht belasten, ja.
Wir gucken das nicht komplett, es sei denn ihr wollt.
Ich wollte euch nur einen Ausschnitt daraus zeigen, weil das Video ist echt hardcore cringe.
Aber was ich euch zeigen wollte ist, wenn sie anfangen zu programmieren.
Oder sollen wir das komplett gucken, es ist ein bisschen cringe.
Aber was ich euch zeigen wollte ist...
Let's go, okay.
Okay, es ist aber Pains Champ, das kann ich euch gleich sagen.
Ich muss mal kurz die Musik ausmachen.
Es ist Pains Champ.
Das ist übrigens Lukas.
Der ist so super motiviert, hat aber kaum Aufrufe, habe ich auch noch nie gesehen von ihm.
An sich ist das Video gut gemacht, aber ich finde den Inhalt übelst cringe,
eben als jemand, der eine physische Ausbildung gemacht hat.
Ihr müsst mal darauf achten, was bei den Monitoren dieser Firma zu sehen ist.
Wie gesagt, der richtig hardcore cringe kommt dann hier so bei 230.
Oder was heißt der hardcore cringe?
Bei 230 kommt das, was ich euch eigentlich zeigen wollte.
Sagt mal, ob es laut genug ist.
By the way, was ist das eigentlich für eine Firma?
Was ist das hier eigentlich für ein Eingang?
Das sieht aus wie ein alles abgestandenes Einfamilienhaus oder so.
Das nicht von der IHK, könnte es aber sein.
Die sagen ja auch noch nichts.
Der dafür bringt es einfach alleine in die Firma auf.
Hallo Lukas, schön, dass du da bist.
Ich will dir heute den Beruf des Fachinformatik etwas näher bringen.
Erst solltest du wissen, es gibt vier Spezialisierungsrichtungen.
Es ist übrigens top aktuell, es gibt vier Spezialisierungen.
Also sprich nicht nur Anwendungsentwicklung, Fachinformatiker, Systemintegration,
sondern auch Data Science, Netzwerktechnik und ich habe keine Ahnung mehr.
Das erste ist der Fachinformatiker für Anwendungsentwicklung.
Alter, es ist leise.
Das zweite ist der Fachinformatiker für Systemintegration.
Es gibt noch einen Fachinformatiker für Daten- und Prozessanalyse.
Wenn ich es lauter mache, fliegen euch die Ohren weg.
Wenn die wieder Musik machen.
So wie ein für digitale Vernetzung.
Und ich sehe, du hast schon die richtigen Sachen an.
Denn wir gehen jetzt zum Kunden. Los geht's.
Ja, da freuen wir uns immer drauf.
Wir gehen zum Kunden, super.
Deswegen habe ich die Physio-Ausbildung gemacht.
Ich besitze immer, egal, ich halte jetzt die Klappe.
Bist du das im Video? Natürlich.
Klar, ich zeige immer nur Videos von mir.
So Lukas, beim Kunden müssen wir jetzt die Anforderungen aufnehmen.
Deine Aufgabe dabei ist es, zuzuhören und mitzuschreiben.
Deshalb überreiche ich dir jetzt...
Ich meine ernsthaft, der Typ ist zum ersten Mal da reingekommen.
Und was soll er da mitschreiben?
Okay, es ist gestellt.
Es ist eh gestellt.
Aber ich finde es so page-champig gemacht.
... und ein Kugelschreiber.
Good.
Hallo Herr Klaus.
Hallo Herr Hinsch.
Herr Klaus.
Übrigens auch geil, wie sie im Hintergrund
die ganze Zeit das Firmenlogo laufen haben.
Also was machen die? Rechnung, Angebot...
Das ist quasi so ein SAP-Lite, oder was?
Ihr individuelles ERP-CHM-System.
Rechnung, Angebot, Kalkulation, Verträge, Workflows, Büro, Personal...
Das ist quasi so ein SAP-Lite, oder?
...
Natürlich ist das extra für den Film so gemacht.
Was können wir denn für Sie tun?
Herr Hinsch, wie schon am Telefon gesagt,
ich habe einen Hausmeisterservice.
Ich habe 10 Mitarbeiter,
habe eine ganze Menge Kunden
und ich muss ungefähr 50 Aufträge pro Woche realisieren.
Mit Excel stoße ich an die Grenzen.
50 Aufträge pro Woche, ja.
Also das Problem ist,
dass er mit Excel überhaupt erst angefangen hat.
Ich brauche etwas, wo meine Kunden
mit den Aufträgen verknüpft werden können
und den Mitarbeitern.
Und ein Auftrag lautet in der Regel 3 Tage.
Ich brauche einen automatischen Vorschlag,
wenn ich in Anfangsdatum...
Was mache ich eigentlich hier?
... umgesetzt habe, wann der Auftrag zu Ende sein muss.
Herr Klaus, das machen wir genauso.
By the way, das ist übrigens viel zu spezifisch.
Das ist übrigens viel zu spezifisch.
Also ich habe ja mit Endkunden
glücklicherweise so gut wie nie was zu tun.
Aber von allem dem, was ich mitbekommen habe,
und auch jetzt nicht nur bei uns,
sondern auch, was man so hört,
ist das nicht, wie Kunden sich das vorstellen?
Dass der wirklich genau sagt, was Sache ist.
Den musst du da schon ein bisschen ausfragen zu.
Lukas, an der Stelle kann man kein fertiges System mehr kaufen,
sondern jetzt müssen wir programmieren.
Jetzt, pass auf, pass auf, jetzt kommt's, jetzt kommt's.
So, Lukas, in der Datoprozessanalyse hast du jetzt mit dem Kunden gesprochen.
Ja, okay, blablabla, gleich, gleich.
Um es anschließend einem Programmierer,
sprich dem Fachinformatiker für Anwendungsentwicklung, zu geben.
Allerdings darfst du jetzt gleich mal selber in diese Rolle schlüpfen.
Und dazu ziehst du dich am besten jetzt erstmal um.
Okay, mach ich.
Das heißt, Fisi braucht Anzug, oder was?
Der braucht Programmierer nicht.
So.
Ihr müsst gleich mal auf den Bildschirm von ihm gucken.
So sieht er schon wie ein richtiger Hacker aus.
Oh, richtig Hacker-Man.
Und schon viel bequemer jetzt in dem Pullover.
Wie sie den Typ da hinten hingesetzt haben.
Guckt euch mal an, wie das hier ausschaut, ne?
Da hinten hingesetzt haben, setzt ihr euch mal hin
und tut mal wichtig programmieren.
Deinen Ausbilder Ringo vorstellen.
Der hat dich durch die Programmierung begleitet.
Ohne Mist, das ist alles ein Familienhaus,
wo sie ein paar Schreibtische reingestellt haben.
Hallo.
Hi, Lukas, schön, dass du da bist.
Kannst du ruhig schon mal hinschauen?
Guck mal gleich auf den Bildschirm.
Nein, das noch nicht, das noch nicht.
Was ist denn das überhaupt hier?
Was bin ich sehend?
Können wir das irgendwie höher auflösen?
Leute, was könnte denn das sein?
Das ist ein Browser?
Oder sowas?
Ist das ein Linux?
Ist das ein Raspberry Pi, worauf der arbeitet?
Das fällt mir jetzt erst auf.
Raspberry Pi als Workstation klingt mir Hardcore-Pains-Champ-ig.
Da kannst du doch nichts drauf entwickeln.
Du kannst schon, aber es ist bestimmt...
Was sehe ich hier?
Ich erkenne es nicht.
Aber gleich kommt das Beste.
Das ist ein Standardwunsch.
Da haben wir schon was vorbereitet.
Das ist bei uns im Editor.
Dann sind die Komponenten unter Add Komponent.
Wenn wir da unter CRM gucken,
haben wir eine Firmliste.
Dann können wir die Firmliste komplex.
Jetzt kannst du da eine ID eingeben.
Das heißt, wir klicken uns eine GUI zusammen.
Die haben eine Raspberry Pi Workstation.
Ach du Scheiße.
Gleich kommt das, weil ich euch zeigen will.
Guckt euch das GUI an.
Jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Dann würde ich lieber in Excel bleiben,
wenn ich dieses GUI sehe.
Da ist ja SAP noch schöner.
Da ist ja SAP Highend.
Das kostet auch 30 Fahrer wahrscheinlich.
Aber es wird noch besser.
Das haben wir jetzt abgeschlossen.
Dann kommen wir zur Individualprogrammierung.
Das war der Wunsch von Kunden.
Die Frist von drei Tagen,
die er standardmäßig gerne haben möchte.
Dann kommen wir deine Mathematikkenntnisse testen.
Dann kannst du ausrechnen,
wie viele Sekunden drei Tage haben.
Wie berechnet man drei Tage auf Basis der Sekunden?
Eine Stunde hat 3600 Sekunden.
Genau so weit wäre ich auch gekommen.
Ich rechne erst mal eine Stunde.
3600 Sekunden.
Mal 24.
Mal drei.
Und das dann nochmal mal drei.
Huge Fivehead-Time.
Hier, guck mal.
Kennt das jemand, was hier rechts ist?
Das wollte ich euch zeigen.
Wisst ihr, was das rechts ist?
Kennt ihr das?
Das ist nicht etwa der Sourcecode
von diesem GUI, was sie gerade programmieren.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man es noch besser sieht.
Gleich.
Gleich sieht man es noch besser.
Ja, natürlich.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Kennt ihr das?
Man sieht es auch sogar oben.
Das hat überhaupt nichts damit zu tun.
Das ist Linux Kernelcode.
Ich glaube nicht, dass die Linux Kernelcode dafür...
Das ist Hacker-Typer.
Was sie da offen haben.
Jetzt hier, Leute.
Los geht's.
Er kann natürlich direkt programmieren
und dann auch Linux Kernelcode.
Gar kein Problem.
Was soll sowas eigentlich immer?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Wahrscheinlich wirkt das irgendwie cooler,
wenn die Leute hier sowas aus-
aus-Hacker-mennen können.
So, ich bin drin, Leute.
Gleich haben wir es.
Und jetzt abschicken.
Bam, easy.
Die wollen halt keinen echten Code präsentieren.
Warum eigentlich nicht?
Ich meine, die sollten doch irgendwie
Teile von ihrer Anwendung finden,
die man leaken kann in einem Video.
So...
Also, so top secret
kann so ein blaues
JavaScript GUI oder was, das ist ja nicht sein.
Was?
Das ist die Unix Timestamp.
Wusste ich auch noch nicht.
Das ist richtig.
Die Zeit hat auch nicht im Jahre 0
begonnen.
Also,
zumindest nicht,
nach unserer heutigen Zeitrechnung
mit vor und nach Christus und sowas.
Die Zeit gibt es eigentlich schon immer.
Also zumindest, solange es Ursache und Wirkung
irgendwie gibt.
Zehnstellig ist es die Frage.
Sekunden oder Millisekunden?
Und du siehst, wir haben Aufträge, wir haben Kunden.
Wenn man auf Aufträge klickt,
kann man Aufträge erstellen.
Da wird hier der 31.8. angezeigt.
Und wenn man da mal gucken...
Welch Magie.
Drei Tage ist der 31.
Hast du also gut gemacht.
Der hat überhaupt nichts gemacht.
Ich meine, okay, es ist gestellt für das Video.
Ich finde es ja in Ordnung, dass man so Sachen
und Videos stellt.
Aber das ist schon so plump in dem Fall.
Das fand ich echt painstampig.
Okay, der Chef erklärt dir das noch ein bisschen mehr
über den Beruf.
Tschüssi.
Lukas, wer hat es dir denn gefallen heute?
Also mir hat es heute hier richtig viel Spaß gemacht.
Ich fand es auch sehr interessant,
einfach mal zu sehen, was so hinter einer Software steckt.
Und am meisten hat es mir natürlich gefallen,
selber mal an so einer Software zu arbeiten.
Ja, natürlich, natürlich.
Alles ein bisschen besser kennenzulernen.
Okay.
Die zwei Sachen, die du heute nicht gelernt hast...
Der Bildschirm schon, aber so muss das sein.
... für die Systemintegration.
Das sind die typischen IT Admins.
Die können Computer installieren, Software installieren,
Drucker einrichten.
Solche Tätigkeiten.
Und die Fachinformatiker für digitale Vernetzung.
Das sind die Experten
für Glasfaser und Kupferkabel.
Das hat eigentlich
mit Vernetzung jetzt relativ
wenig zu tun.
Und
ich wünsche dir auf alle Fälle viel Spaß
bei deiner weiteren Ausbildungssuche.
Also mit Vernetzung
ist nicht unbedingt gemein, dass ich mich
gut mit Glasfaser und Kupferkabel auskenne.
Ja, und Drucker einrichten ist klar.
Und damit sage ich Tschüss.
Oh, dieses Video ist immer so Paints-Champ.
Das ist echt der Wahnsinn.
Das Schlimmste fand ich das mit Hacker-Typer.
Also die Hacker-Typer-Geschichte ist wirklich
hardcore Paints-Champ
in der S gewesen.
Ach Moment, steht es in den Kommentaren?
Wartet mal.
Wirklich eine tolle Idee am Hacker-Typer
zu öffnen.
Ja, das stimmt.
Liegt das daran, dass sie nur rumklicken?
Ah, Digga, du bist legit
10 aus 10.
Was genau möchte
er uns damit sagen?
War echt so fremd schön.
Ja, sage ich euch ja, sage ich euch ja.
Richtig, richtig Paints-Champing
haben wir da gerade betrieben.
So, was, was können wir uns jetzt als Nächstes noch geben?
Zeig mal her.
Wir lassen uns jebaiten von Levelcap.
Und ich muss meine Klappe halten, dass ich nicht
aus Versehen irgendwas liege, was ich auch nicht sagen darf.
Ich tue einfach so als weiß ich
von nichts und reakte
auf das, wie uns Levelcap mal wieder
hat.
By the way, was ich halt
geil finde bei Levelcap, der Typ
weiß das.
Also der weiß das genau so
im Endeffekt, wie ich es mittlerweile
auch weiß. Und der tun die
ich finde das so geil, wie sie immer so tun,
als wüssten sie nichts.
Moment, haben wir das nicht schon gesehen.
Sagt mal, nimmt der jedes Mal exakt die gleichen
Clips? Der Clip mit dem
Boot kommt bestimmt auch wieder.
Ja, das wissen wir.
Am neunten.
Guckt, es kommt gleich der Clip
mit dem Boot wieder.
Ja, dieses Zeug habe
ich auch bekommen, wo ich mich gefragt habe,
was genau möchten wir Battlefield damit sagen?
Guck mal, das Boot ist wieder am Start.
Er bringt immer die exakt gleichen Clips.
Levelcapture Bay ist die Tradition, ja.
Ja, das Ding habe ich auch gekriegt.
Das ist ja mittlerweile entschlüsselt, aber juckt mich so
überhaupt nicht.
Leaked.
Stealth.
Der kann echt gut tun, als wüsste
er es nicht.
Ich hätte echt meine
Probleme,
darüber jetzt zu reden, drei Minuten
und das irgendwie so
dastehen zu lassen,
und nichts Falsches zu erzählen,
das würde ich gerade hinkriegen.
Wenn ein Leak richtig ist,
dann blende ein Emote ein.
Ne.
Das einzige, was ich leaken kann,
das einzige, was ich leaken kann,
was ich weiß,
von Battlefield 6 ist,
dass die Entwickler bei DICE immer mehr nach
Wikinger ausschauen, aber gut, sind ja auch
Schweden, aber da war ich
diesmal echt überrascht, die können eins zu eins
aus Vikings sein.
Warum weiß Max mehr als wir?
Weil ich
Boomer Influencer bin.
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum die mich eingeladen haben.
Ich habe die letzten zwei Battlefields nur geflamed.
Aber wisst ihr, was die Kacke ist von Battlefield
auf Steam?
Du kannst ja das Spiel nicht direkt
launchen über Steam, du musst ja, also,
oder korrigiert mich, wenn ich falsch liege.
Warst du bei dem? Ne, ne, alles
online.
Die Sache ist halt,
du musst trotzdem Origin starten.
Du startest Steam, startest das Game, das startet
Origin, das startet Battlelog.
Das ist hier irgendwie Fail.
Hast du schon das neue Technoos von
Gamers Nexus gesehen? Ne.
Gibt es da was wichtiges?
Battlefield 6 hat kein
Battlefield 4 hat kein
Battlelog?
Doch, klar hat
Battlefield 4 Battlelog.
Oder?
Bring ich es jetzt durcheinander?
Klar hat Battlefield 4 Battle
nicht mehr?
Wie hat Battlefield 4
hat kein
Wir müssen doch
Battlelog haben, du kannst das doch online sogar
noch auswählen.
Ich sehe sogar online
in Battlelog Leute, die Battlefield 4 spielen.
Ach, war deaktiviert.
Was hat man dann gemacht? Ingame Browser
oder was?
Da müssen sie alle jetzt, da müssen sie
Nvidia, Nvidia macht irgendwas, da müssen sie
gleich hinterher.
Ja Moment, das muss, das geht
aber nicht so einfach. Also
ich hab mich da vor einer Weile mal ein bisschen
drüber informiert, also das ist jetzt
nichts, was man einfach einschaltet, so wie
normales Anti-Aliasing,
Anti-Aliasing,
wie immer man es genau ausspricht,
wo du das Game einfach in der simpelsten Variante
in höhere Auflösung renderst und dann wieder
runter. Das hier ist was, das muss
explizit in die
Variante auflösen und
dann wieder runter.
Das hier ist was, das muss explizit
in die Engine eingebaut werden.
Das kann man nicht einfach mal so dazu
schalten. Also die Chance
für alte Games,
jetzt einfach hier, oder etwas ältere
Games, wo die kein Patch mal zu rausbringen
wollen, das einfach einzuschalten, dann geht's.
Das wird wahrscheinlich nicht so sein.
Wenn du schon nichts leaken kannst,
bist du zumindest optimistisch, was das nächste
Battlefield angeht, ja.
Bin ich, tatsächlich.
Ich war relativ gehypt,
aber
ja, seht ihr dann am neunten.
Ich habe im Lost direkt was aufgenommen,
als der Hype noch frisch war,
und das können wir aber erst am neunten
laden dann.
Es kommt am neun, ja, das ist kein Leak.
Das
ist ja schon bekannt.
Man muss aber sagen,
Nvidia macht halt auch einiges,
dass die Leute bei Nvidia hängen bleiben.
Beispielsweise diese Nvidia
Reflex-Geschichte, die
ihre DLSS-Geschichte,
Nvidia
Dings, wie heißt, Voice
Sachen. Also die haben vieles
zusätzlich in ihrem Ökosystem, oder auch
Shadowplay, wo AMD
versucht auch was in der Richtung zu machen, aber
es meistens nicht ganz so polished ist.
Also Nvidia
tut da einiges, für dass die Leute nicht von Nvidia
Grafikkarten wegkommen.
Machen wir heute mal wieder den
Valomat, wegen der Wahlen in Sachsen-Anhalt.
Vielleicht, wenn wir am Ende
noch Zeit haben.
Ich kann es schon mal aufmachen,
aber wenn, schon ganz am Ende.
Aber ich bin ja
nicht in
Sachsen-Anhalt.
Im Endeffekt sind wir stehen geblieben.
Der Witz ist ja, es bringt ja noch nicht mal was,
wenn man heutzutage sagt, hey, das ist die
richtige Grafikkarte für mich, die will ich mir holen,
weil man bekommt sie eh nicht.
Das ist ja das Problem aktuell.
Geht eigentlich der Preis-Champ noch?
Leute, ich mach die 3080
TI rein, sobald der Crawler
die 3080 TI kann.
Die Wall-Zone-Defs.
Wenn die irgendwas fixen,
sind 20 andere Sachen kaputt.
Also ich verfolge es, ich spiele ja Wall-Zone nicht mal aktiv,
ich verfolge es nur am Rande.
Also das, was Ravensofter abliefert,
ist ja wirklich an Lächerlichkeit
kaum noch zu überbieten.
Es gibt Skins, die unsichtbar sind.
Es gibt die krassesten
Balancing-Scheiße ever, die man
je gesehen hat.
Es sind, jetzt sind glaube ich Stuntgranaten
wieder kaputt seit einer Woche oder so.
Es ist komplett im Arsch,
was die treiben.
Ich verfolge es nur noch
so auf Reddit und nebenbei. Ich kann mir das Game
nicht geben.
Würdest du den
GPU-Markt irgendwie regulieren,
wenn du könntest schlechter Markt finden?
Nö. Ich würde den GPU-Markt nicht regulieren.
Ich gehe davon aus,
dass
NVIDIA und AMD
da ein eigenes Interesse dran haben,
dass Graphikkarten für Games
und Gamer
wieder verfügbarer werden.
Weil es kann denen letztendlich nicht
egal sein, ob es Miner oder Gamer kaufen.
Die machen ihr ganzes Geld mit
ganzen Promotions, alles drum herum.
Gaming und Gaming-Ökosystem.
Das Einzige, was ich mir vorstellen könnte,
ist, dass die normale Edition,
die wollen sich das Geschäft mit Minerkarten
wahrscheinlich auch nicht entgehen lassen.
Was ich mir vorstellen könnte, dass die eben
rausbringen, für mining geeignet
und welche nicht für mining geeignet.
Naja.
Wenn man es braucht.
Also wisst ihr, was ich
prefieren würde bei Far Cry?
Wenn da ein gutes Gameplay rauskommt.
Ob das jetzt
Third Person oder First Person ist.
Ich mein, First Person gehört irgendwie mit dabei.
Aber ob das jetzt noch ein Third Person hat
oder nicht, okay aus.
Okay, das ist cool.
Hellish VR.
Hellish VR, Headset, Brille.
Äh, wäre das das erste Game,
was ich spielen würde.
Aber ich sehe es immer noch nicht ein, wie für ein Game das zu kaufen.
Ich weiß, jetzt kommt der Chat
wieder und sagt, Max guck doch
vor Airporn. Aber es ist mir nicht
wert, für ein Game eine Brille zu kaufen.
Ne, den Portalmod haben sie nicht ausprobiert.
Anzeige ist raus.
Es wäre jetzt
mal interessant, ein Foto zu sehen.
Ich mein, ganz ehrlich,
ein Foto von so einem alten Gemäuer,
äh,
ja, gibt's, gibt's halt einige.
Okay.
Ha, okay, das ist natürlich
hell.
Hat da,
meine Frage an die Pupke-Spieler,
hat danach irgendjemand gefragt?
Wie ist eigentlich so der Stand
vom Pupke? Ist das mittlerweile mal halbwegs
fertig? Also sprich, läuft das
halbwegs gut?
Ja.
Also sprich, läuft das halbwegs gut?
Oder
sind die
Spieler zufrieden damit?
Dead.
Spiel für Pupke, die Koreaner
mögen das immer noch.
Das hat die Welt gebraucht.
congress niemals
Games vorbestellen lohnt sich einfach null in der heutigen Zeit.
avant verdACT
hier
Gz doom engine und so far it looks like a ton of fun
It's the latest in a new wave of retro fps titles that utilize or emulate old game engines
Modern gameplay mechanics and visuals so laco is getting a demo soon that you can get access to by subscribing to the developers
Peter hat das ist doch bestimmt sponsored oder tree on account
Hopefully open access isn't too far behind and that wraps it up for this weekend gaming as always guys
Thank you so much for watching and I'll see you next time. This is level cap signing off
So hat er uns wieder schön gebatet mit kaum inhalt so muss es sein
Ist es jetzt eigentlich true dass das neue battlefield was auf ea play rauskommt keine ahnung
Morgen marks kennst du ein programm was im netzwerk die berechtigung eines kleines ausliest
Das ist windows ne kein schimmer
Windows sachen kannst du mich nicht fragen da habe ich keinen plan von
Absolut kein plan
Okay das was meint ihr wie lange dieses schloss wieder stand hält also ich tippe mal so auf 15 sekunden dann ist es auf
Das muss ich gerade an permettre
The last thing I usually look at when evaluating a lock is the key.
And that's what caught my attention.
This Chinese lock that was sold in the U.S. on Amazon
has the name of a Turkish lock company on it, Kalei Kaleep.
Looking at the bottom of the key, I can guess why that might be.
It appears that the keys were originally produced a bit too large
and had to be shaved down.
You can see where the chrome on the bottom is missing.
I suspect for that reason these were either rejected by Kalei
or were never sent to them.
Rather than discarding the work, it seems they were sold on the cheap
and eventually made their way into the package with this reset lock.
Again, that's all I guess, but I can't imagine how else
a mutilated Turkish key made its way to me with a Chinese lock.
Maybe I'm the only one who finds this interesting,
but I actually enjoy finding odd quirks like this
that give me some insight into how the lock industry abroad actually works.
So, I suppose I should pick this now.
I'm going to use bottom of the keyway tension with this medium wiper insert
and a standard hook in 18 thousandths.
Click out of one, click on two, nothing on three.
Click out of four, click out of five, and we got this open.
Okay, folks, it's not a terribly interesting or...
Easy.
Ja, ich hab das Video gesehen, wo er dieses unknackbare Schloss gezeigt hat,
wo er dann irgendwie sowas durchgeschoben hat
und es war trotzdem wieder knackbar, easy.
Acht Sekunden.
Oh, das ist ja hier...
Ist das schon langsam für seine Verhältnisse?
Ich darf mir nicht so viel von diesen Videos angucken,
sonst krieg ich die nämlich nur noch vorgeschlagen.
Ich hab meine ganzen Videos in voll mit so einem Crap.
Schau bitte, das nix, ich hab mir zu viele Videos davon angeguckt,
ich krieg jetzt nur noch diesen Kram vorgeschlagen
und nicht mehr das, was ich im Stream gucken kann.
Übrigens, es gibt ein neues Alpha 4 Games Video,
das gucken wir uns jetzt mal an.
Schon nicht gesehen.
Ich hätte auch gar nicht mitbekommen, dass der eins hochgeladen hat.
Ähm, hätte das YouTube nicht empfohlen vorhin.
Kannst Musik ausmachen.
Okay, ein bisschen zu leise.
So, das war die ganze...
Ich kann mir Halo Waffennamen einfach nicht merken.
Ich bin da zu noobig für dieses normale Halo-Alien-Psygel-Schuss-Ding.
Naja, wenn's wegfliegt.
Also, reden wir über Persönlichkeit in Waffenanimationen.
Nachladeanimationen oder First-Person-Animationen an sich
sind eigentlich Mittel zum Zweck.
Irgendwann kam mal jemand auf die Idee,
dass sein First-Person-Spiel sichtbare Hände haben sollte.
Anschließend hat man noch ne Waffe dazu gepackt.
Später kam dann das Nachladen dazu,
was irgendeine Form visuelles Feedback haben musste.
Anstatt einer Fortschrittsleiste.
Und ein paar Jahrzehnte voller Entwicklung später
sind wir nun da angekommen, wo wir heute sind.
Ich muss ehrlich sagen,
ich finde, heute ist es fast schon ein bisschen übertrieben.
Es gibt ja diese Vergleichsvideos, Call of Duty, In-Game,
Nachladeanimationen in echt.
Weiß nicht, ob ihr die kennt.
Warte mal. COD, Reload in real life.
Ja, das da meine ich.
Es sieht halt echt aus wie in dem Game.
Ich finde, teilweise ist es ein bisschen übertrieben in den Games
mittlerweile schon, was die da machen.
Ich meine, du hast dann fünf verschiedene Dinger an Reloads.
Dann hast du irgendwie, wenn du gerade am Sliden bist,
noch mal fünf verschiedene Reloads und sonst was.
Also ja, ich meine, es schadet auf jeden Fall nix.
Olinio sagt, hey Max, das ist so geil.
Ich habe dich über sieben Jahre oder so
seit drei Monaten auf YouTube wiederentdeckt und jetzt sogar im Stream. Nice.
Ja, es gibt ja nichts.
Also spätestens zur Battlefield Release gibt es ein neues Video.
Ich meine, wie gesagt, das ist halt real life und kein Game.
Wenn man das nicht weiß, könnte man durchaus denken, es ist aus einem COD.
Man die kleinen Bewegungen vom Arm und jetzt dieses bisschen gewackele
und so geben das schon noch Preis, dass es ein echtes Video ist.
Aber es könnte schon aus dem Game sein.
Das ist doch CGI. Also mittlerweile ist es wirklich schwierig zu unterscheiden.
Kann sich noch irgendjemand an diese
an diese rare Nachlade Animation aus Battlefield Hardline erinnern?
Das ist das ist das ist real life hier.
Es sieht halt einfach aus, wie aus dem Game.
Man sieht zum Beispiel auch an der Uhr Spiegelung und so was.
Wie lange geht das eigentlich noch?
Ah, jetzt ist es vorbei.
Ja, das war das war schon echt hier Battlefield Hardline Rare Reloads.
Was ist das eigentlich für eine für eine mega kacke Auflösung?
Guck so was die die fand ich schon ganz cool.
Das war dann irgendwie eins von hundert Reloads
oder so war so eine so eine extra Special Reload Animation.
Aber jetzt gucken wir das Alpha 4 Games Video erst mal fertig.
Super detaillierten Waffen Animationen für jede mögliche Situation.
Dieser Zweig der Industrie hat sich in den letzten Jahren so weit entwickelt,
dass ein Auge für detailgetreuen Realismus bei Schusswaffen längst die Regeln
und nicht mehr die Ausnahme ist, was Musik ausfällt, was man als Spieler
für selbstverständlich hält, worauf man meist gar nicht mehr achtet,
einfach weil man schon in so vielen Spielen so oft nachgeladen hat.
Man entfernt halt ein Magazin und packt Neues rein.
Who cares, wie realistisch das aussieht?
Grund genug, also ein wenig Stil mit reinzubringen.
Wie wäre es mit so einem lässigen Wegwerfen des alten Magazins?
So ein cooler Flick oder so?
Sicherheitshalber noch ein unnötig starker Slap hinterher?
Bewegungen, die eins zu eins aus Hollywood Blockbustern stammen,
weil Terminator ist halt ein cooler Film oder doch gleich was komplett Verrücktes.
Animationen, bei denen der Realismus gelegentlich etwas leiden muss,
um dafür dem Spiel ein gutes Stück mehr Persönlichkeit zu geben.
Und eines der besten Beispiele dafür ist wohl Black von 2006.
Was? Der buddelt da immer Games aus?
Hab ich noch nie was von gehört, kennt das hier, man?
Ein Shooter, in dem die Waffe an sich im Vordergrund stehen sollte
und man keinerlei Zeit verschwenden wollte, um das Spiel wegzumachen.
Slow-Mo Waffen im Hauptmenü, eine ausführliche Draw-Animation direkt zum Spielstart,
Türen, die erst aufgeschossen werden müssen und jede Menge Explosionen überall.
Das Game sieht in der Tat nicht so spannend aus.
Ein Spiel mit realen Waffen, die aber nicht genauso wie in echt aussehen.
Eine AK legt man zum Beispiel nicht so nach und die Patronenhülse kann sowieso...
Ich wollte gerade sagen, der Auswurf von den Patronen ist auf der falschen Seite,
es sei denn, man möchte es immer schön ins Gesicht kriegen.
Weiter raus.
Das ist an sich kein Fehler, wir sind hier nicht bei Counter Strike 1.6.
Man dachte sich einfach nur, es sieht so interessanter aus.
Hier haben wir ein Spiel, bei dem man sich Zeit lässt, bei dem Visiere erst aufgeploppt werden,
in Magazine reingeguckt wird und allgemein wird jeder einzelne Schritt des Nachladens
möglichst gut und vor allem lang in Szene gesetzt,
während die Animation innerhalb von Kämpfen etwas abgekürzt wird.
Es hat ein bisschen was von so einer Waffeninspektionstaste,
Jahre bevor das überhaupt ne Sache war, nur halt fürs Nachladen.
Und dank der tiefen Schärfe bekommt man ja sowieso nichts anderes mehr mit.
Aber es braucht nicht gleich puren Gun-Porn für gute Animationen.
Es geht auch anders.
Gunfire Reborn ist so ein Spiel, dass ich in den letzten Monate
besonders für seine großartigen Animationen schätzen gelernt habe.
Das mit einem coolen grünen Birdspiel...
Sagt mir auch Null.
Dabei ist es nicht einmal technisch brillant animiert oder sowas,
sondern einfach super befriedigend anzusehen.
Wie diese Kaffeekanne hier aufgeklappt wird, sich die Kammer immer noch etwas mitdreht
und unser grobschlechtiger Vogel sie mit ruckartigen Bewegungen wiederfüllt,
hat so einen ganz bestimmten Rhythmus dabei, den man auch bei anderen...
Warum gibt es eigentlich ein Game, wo sich Vögel gegenseitig abschießen?
Okay, das ist doch, weil es geht, weil es geht wahrscheinlich.
So wie bei diesem Sturmgewehr jeder Schritt sauber...
Wieso nicht? Genau.
...während der letzte Schritt noch ganz kurz gehalten wird, bevor es weitergeht.
Oder wie dieser Armwurst hier ihren Clip rauswirft, bevor man lässig den nächsten oben draufslappt.
Oder wie snappy man seine Kunai mit diesen typischen Endposen wirft.
Oder wie man all die beweglichen Parts dieser Shogun-Shotgun hier
mit der Animation besonders betonen wollte.
Oder diese Shotgun hier.
Oder der da.
Die Kiffer-Echse.
Es ist alles so super snappy und bis auf wenige Ausnahmen und dieses schreckliche
Wir sind ein Roguelite, also gibt es Perks, damit alle Animationen vorgespult werden,
ist das halt alles großartig.
Copyright Game, danke für den Sub.
Es ist leicht cartoony und nicht gerade realistisch,
aber mit einem Fokus auf Einbrüche...
Stopp, das wäre jetzt nicht so mein Game.
Das Schießen kombiniert mit dem Nachladen,
das ergibt durch diese deutlichen Bewegungen fast so eine Art Beat.
Das macht nicht nur Spaß anzugucken, sondern macht es auch viel leichter,
wenn man wieder ballern kann.
Allerdings ist das so ein Aspekt, der recht schwierig zu beschreiben ist,
wenn man ihn nicht gerade selbst fühlt.
Es ist ein gutes Koop-Spiel, okay.
Also probier es mal anhand der Doom-Shotgun zu verdeutlichen.
Wie heißt das Game? Ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung.
Ich glaube, wenn man nach Rogue-Lite-Birds sucht, wird man das finden.
In einer Bewegung, die trotz weniger Frames nachvollziehbar ist,
gefolgt vom nächsten Schuss.
In der ganzen Bewegung steckt etwas Power, etwas Anschlossenheit
und es macht die Feuerrate viel leichter einschätzbar,
als wenn sie fehlen würde.
Das stimmt, da habe ich noch nicht schon gedacht.
Ja, das stimmt, das stimmt.
Selbiges trifft auf die Schrotfünte von Serious Samson.
Am besten, was ich halt mag, sind,
wenn die in Games noch zusätzlich so eine zweite Ebene einbauen,
dass du Reload-Cancels machen kannst und so was.
Das finde ich cool.
Das fand ich beispielsweise in Bad Company 2 auch nice,
dass du die Shotgun Reload cancelen konntest
und dann irgendwie 0,05 Sekunden oder so schneller schießen.
Über die Zeit ist diese furchtbar animiert,
aber sie gibt durch diese deutliche und durchgehende Bewegung
ein sehr gutes Gefühl für den Feuer.
Bei Serious Sam muss ich immer denken an.
Aaaahhhhhh!
Und damit auch den gesamten Combat Flow wieder.
Als Kontrast hier mal die Schrotflünte von Doom 2016.
Technisch zwar einwandfrei, aber ohne Kraft dahinter,
ohne Betonung auf irgendwas.
Eine Bewegung, die man aus dem Augen mitbekommt
und die völlig untergeht.
Die doppelläufige Schrotflünte wird ebenso lustlos nachgefüllt
und dann ohne viel Schwung wieder zugeklappt.
nicht unbedingt schlecht und bei weitem nicht der schlimmste fahrer
hat er recht das ich will ich will jetzt nicht sagen ist mir auch aufgefallen weil
das stimmt nicht also nicht bewusst ja aber da ist schon was dran aber für den
secret reload in der bettelfeier machen dann doch lieber zu dumm 2 gegriffen
wobei hier aber sowieso niemand an die slickness von deep rock galactic rankommt
und was oder hier ich will das kein der krept immer games aus 3 etwas leblos
halo reach deutlich mehr wumms hinter was rein zufällig passt weil sie den
reach auch mehr schaden macht immerhin ist es auch aufgabe der animation der
gameplay information zu vermitteln ein schwerer rückstoß oder eine
unkontrollierbare streuung sollte im idealfall auch in der animation
erkennbar sein ist etwas stark soll es sich auch stark anfühlen
nun hatten wir schon ein spiel das waffen als persönlichkeit hat eins das
waffen mit persönlichkeit hat wie wir es nun also noch mit spielen bei denen die
waffen der spielfigur persönlichkeit geben
team fortress 2 war glaube ich so eins der ersten spiele damals bei dem er
auch viel wie viel charakter man in die bewaffnung von figuren und der
handhabung dieser waffen stecken kann ja aber aber aber aber hüte verkaufen
wichtig wie seine mini baby schrotflinte durchladen muss oder wie sich der
engineer und der scout die gleiche pistole teilen aber nur letzterer all
seine überschüssige energie ins nachladen reinsteckt ich finde das hätte
welch bei behalten sollen es so hatte damals in der vita diese
desert eagle animation das sorgte für einigen backlash war man eher so was
hier gewohnt war aber anstatt sie komplett zu verwerfen
hätte sie einfach den cts gegeben einfach diesen kleinen unterschied in der
persönlichkeit ja wenn ich finde ich diese team fortress idee einige jahre
später wieder auf und bietet einen haufen bunter leute deren
persönlichkeit du sogar aus deren animationen ablesen kannst manche sind
professionell und präzise bei allem was sie tun andere sind locker und
verspielt oder auch einfach mal komplett wahnsinnig mit einer waffe er hätte das
auch eine multiplayer match filmen können aber ich glaube das hat er nicht
gemacht weil er hätte so gerätscht dass er das video abgebrochen hätte
offer was ist eines der most in inducing games die so gibt die kurz vorm zerfallen
ist dass deren character design dann sogar noch in so kleinigkeiten wie dem
kamerawackeln beim laufen eingeflossen ist ist dann nur das finale das muss man
das muss man blizzard wirklich lassen also so vom grundgedanken ist auf
aber wirklich ein geiles game auch die helden sind so nice unterschiedlich
gemacht im prinzip ist ja ist aber so der helden cast ist das ding von
overwatch schlechthin die maps sind jetzt nicht so der wahnsinn ja die
spielmodi sind jetzt nicht so der wahnsinn die helden ist das was
overwatch ausmacht alles andere drumherum ist so mittel mittelmäßig aber
der helden cast und das zusammenspiel ist halt das was
overwatch möglich zu overwatch macht
crisis 23 haben andere animation fürs nachladen je nachdem in welchem anzug
modus man sich gerade befindet eine normale eine vorsichtige was die news
von overwatch 2 hören sich bis jetzt sehr geil eine ja so viele news gibt es
ja nicht also die einzigen sachen die ich jetzt nennenswert mitbekommen habe
ist dass es 5a 5a teams jetzt nur noch gibt wobei ich da echt mal eine zweifel
habe ob das naja gut sie haben es mit mit balancing und guten maps auch nicht
hinbekommen in overwatch als guten spielmodi guten maps auch in overwatch
einzig hinbekommen aber ok es gibt neuen spielmodus es 2 cp fliegt raus und es
sind nur noch fünf leute in einem team das ist so das einzige was ich so von
overwatch 2 jetzt multiplayer technisch interessant finde ob der single player
oder diese koord mission irgendwie gut werden ich weiß nicht
5a teams haben die wegen der langen dps q time gemacht inwieweit bringt das was
du meinst weil du ein weil du einen tank spieler weniger brauchst ein volles
team zu kriegen
ob das ob das jetzt so unterschied macht
wenn du hast kleinere teams aber immer noch gleich viel dps spieler
die q time ist ja glaube ich nur sonderlich lang wenn du ab einem gewissen
level bist also ich denke mal ab master plus wird es langsamer
zumindest habe ich den eindruck immer dass du ab da halt deutlich länger
wartest und ab und ab gm top 500 schon mal gar nicht ganz vorbei
was zehn minuten in platin na gut es liegt eher daran dass wahrscheinlich
kaum noch eine overwatch spiel im vergleich zu den millionen die sie da
immer auf ihrer home page schreiben
nur dass die meisten tanks gar keinen gar keinen bock auf den change haben und
overwatch 2 erst gar nicht ausprobieren green 0 die werden keine chance haben
der multiplayer von overwatch 1 und overwatch 2 mit exakter gleich also wenn
overwatch 2 rauskommt wird auch overwatch 1 5a teams haben und keine
tanks mehr also keine zwei tanks also du kannst gar nicht sagen ich spiele
weiter auf overwatch 1 das wird nicht funktionieren ja twitch animierte emotes
da bin ich der erste der eins hat er sage ich euch und noch eine deutlich gröbere
im panzer modus und das für alle waffen oder du kannst auch zeigen dass die
spielfigur ein absoluter amateur ist so wie in der kampagne von modern warfare
2019 und warum sollte man dann overwatch 2 kaufen
ja weil man diese vielleicht diese komischen singleplayer dinger spielen
will und die bessere grafik haben will keine ahnung
eine mission in der du ein junges mädchen spielst und die kampagne von modern
warfare die war so verschenkt das hätten sie viel besser machen können von vom
ansatz her fand ich die gar nicht schlecht aber das war so verschenkt ich
muss sagen ich fand auch die cold war kampagne total verschenkt die war die
hatte die hatte so das letzte drittel war richtig nice und auch so wie es von
der plekops kampagne erwarten würde der rest war einfach nur langweilig
sogar das schießen an sich spiegelt sehr gut erkennbar wieder dass sie keinerlei
kampfverfahren hat
oder wie ifen aus resident evil zwischen den teilen 7 und 8 eine deutlich
professionellere art bekommen wir mit schusswaffen umgeht er zum beispiel die
pistole beim laufen nicht mehr hoch hält weil er aus plattgründen waffentraining
bekam zumindest ist es schneller als einhändig nachzuladen oder du
übertreibst es gleich andersrum und machst ein spiel voller würfe und spins
und flips und patronen die in die schrottwürde reingeworfen werden das ist
auch immer ganz unterhaltsam wobei man es damit auch nicht zu sehr
übertreiben sollte weil die novelty von shadow war ja das remake war echt nicht
schlecht animations aus battlefield wären zum beispiel weit weniger lustig
und besonders wenn man sie jedes dritte mal zu sehen bekommt und es gibt noch
unzählige andere beispiele wie man es macht oder eben nicht macht oder was auch
immer eigentlich sollte das ja ein format über allerhand unsinn werden und nicht
exklusiv über nachlade animation aber das passiert halt da setzte dich an ein
follow-up zu einem kleinen aber recht coolen video und plötzlich macht ein
ganzes fass auf animation ist ein super faszinierendes thema bei dem
vermutlich eine menge leute unterschätzen wie wichtig es ist damit
sich ein spiel egal welche art egal in welchem genre überhaupt gut anfühlt
das stimmt zumal das auch so eine undefinierte geschichte ist also hast
games da hast du das gefühl so nach dem auto ja das ist nice das haut rein das
fühlt sich gut an und du hast spiele die sehen auch geil aus aber irgendwas fehlt
und man kann da oftmals nicht so den finger genau drauf legen und sagt so
das ist es jetzt da muss man schon bisschen gedanken machen dabei gibt es
nicht immer nur gut und schlecht oder richtig und falsch jedes spiel hat einen
anderen focus ein anderen stil und die animation müssen immer zum jeweiligen
spiel und vor allem ich muss sagen wähler ent da haben sie es mit den
waffen also meiner meinung nach haben sie es ein bisschen verkackt und zwar die
original waffen und so ich meine ich sehen finde ich relativ billig aus aber
ist alles ok was ich halt null überhaupt nicht mag ist dass die
wellerand waffenskins überhaupt nichts mit den den oder die diese epic
waffenskins überhaupt nichts mit den ursprünglichen waffen zu tun haben
genau zum beispiel diese diese drachen skins das sieht einfach nur billig aus
und ist schweine teuer nation müssen immer zum jeweiligen spiel und vor allem
in die spielregeln reinpassen wenn etwas schnell sein muss aufgrund von
gameplay muss es dementsprechend auch animiert werden
darum bin ich auch immer so schnell bad hört wenn es darum geht die
animationen einfach vorzuspulen da hast du die arbeit eines animatörs der frame
für frame versucht menschliche bewegung mit gewicht und allem nachzubauen und
irgendjemand beschleunigt es einfach ganz egal wie es danach aussieht bis man
irgendwann gar nicht mehr erkennen kann was überhaupt passieren soll
gott killing floor du machst mich so traurig oder man sich gleich völlig zum
affen macht also ja faszinierendes thema und ein gigantisches themen und dann
haben wir bisher auch nur über shooter und auch nur über waffen animationen in
shootern geredet andere genres machen doch viel cooleren stuff und auch nicht
ganz so cool es fing an als mittel zum zweck um gameplay information zu
vermitteln und es ist fantastisch dass es so viel mehr ist so viel style hat
sogar etwas erzählen war das eben ghost war das ghost kann ich ja nur noch
dunkel gerade war das eben ghost
es fing an als mittel zum zweck um gameplay information zu vermitteln und
es ist fantastisch dass es so viel mehr ist so viel ja das war ghost
ich habe schon wieder fast verdrängt dass das spiel überhaupt existiert hat
style hat sogar etwas erzählen kann und immer wieder irgendetwas besonderes ins
augesticht also wenn es wenn es zwei color futures gibt die ich komplett
verdrängt habe dann ist es ghost und advanced warfare
weil ich ehrlich sagen muss ich mein cold war auch weil cold war habe ich ja
gar nicht mal richtig versucht im multiplayer ich war schon so ich war schon
es stimmt infinite warfare habe ich mir gar nicht gekauft hast recht das habe
ich schon komplett vergessen cold war habe ich im multiplayer nicht mal
angefasst weil ich eh wusste dass mich skill based matchmaking wird also krass
abfacken wird dass ich mir das nicht geben kann
in code ich weiß nicht ob das das richtige für den stream ist hier
das glaube ich das glaube ich das glaube ich für heute zu big brain für
aufwachen stream da braucht man zu viel hirn für das video
doch das ist gut ok wenn ihr das sagt wenn ihr das sagt da gucken wir uns jetzt an
das gibt es wirklich stimmt wir haben heute schon ordentlich
sapp gesapps gehabt dann ist der IQ so weit geschehen dass man sowas glaube ich
ich jetzt angucken kann wir sind alle big brain max also chat ich glaube euch ja
viel aber das nicht
warum moment das muss ich ausprobieren das muss ich ausprobieren ob das stimmt
ich mache mein links vm an sonst fange ich mir doch den keylogger ein oder
sowas man weiß man weiß ja nie man weiß ja nie moment das muss ich mir jetzt
angucken wie heißt die seite
rick roll.com alles klar nur in firefox aha das wäre nämlich das nächste was
ich ausprobiert hätte wie sieht es in unterschiedlichen browsers aus das muss
jetzt ausprobieren sack sack
firefox ich weiß nicht die schaffen sich eh selbst ab so die letzten jahre über
max du weißt dass das streamer nur so big brain ist wie sein chat ein das
streamer also der brain des streamers und chats korreliert direkt mit
subscriber anzahl zumindest ist bei mir so so weit der speedchamp den kann ich jetzt
mal kurz weg machen nachher hat jemand gefragt wie wir das
wie wir das machen wir werden das im stream weiter weiter entwickeln
also was war das hier the rick roll.com
ok wieso hat doch source code
rick roll hat doch source code so alles gut
ach hier hat es keinen source code die veloper tools darf man nicht aufmachen
ok verstehe
stimmt warum hat es hier kein source interessant
interessant ok gucken wir uns das mal an
also ich wüsste jetzt nicht wie man das wie man das machen kann aber schauen
wir mal und im chrome im chrome ist es nicht so oder was
rickroll.com
warum gibt es das auch nicht ok schauen wir mal
there's no code here nothing nada how well let me explain let me give you
guys some context here die musik zu dem video an
then two months ago i created my blog basically redirects to the music video
composed with you know intricate yeah okay it's a rick roll but obviously
people were very happy about it you know like very much flattered by my
research blog i was having the fun of my day right until this dude out of
nowhere comes with a PSA instead of visiting the webpage and getting rick
rolled he tries to uncover the code behind the website as you can see this
is the code i was just simply redirecting the page with a location
assignment in javascript once the page was loaded okay pretty simple actually
too simple anyone could have you know seen through it easily so i decided to
make this a bit harder
okay now check this out well it's not that obvious right i'm including some
google analytics code people ignore that usually and then i'm including the safe
dot js the simply console logs and reloads the page but what people don't
know is the fact that the script that's coming from google is actually an
injected one basically it's a gadget i can inject some code and i would get
back the same thing and people would think it's legit coming from google and
ignore it generally speaking then this injected code would be register a
service worker which would act yes verwendet eigentlich auch kaum jemand
ich habe übrigens überlegt ob wir unsere speed test seite nicht mit
webwerker machen sollten für speed test whenever the page is loaded it would
make a request to fetch the same dot js script right but this service worker
leute des videos übelst langweilig wollen wir uns das angucken
der chat sagt zwar das ist nicht schlecht aber ich finde es nicht
sonderlich spannend das ist auch so das ist auch so resident sleeper gemacht
nee ich weiß nicht skip okay excellent skip aufhören ja ja ich finde es auch zu
langweilig zumindest für heute morgen finde ich es zu langweilig ich mache
man puken mag vielleicht gucken wir uns den fahrer das da jetzt war lomar nee
nee wir waren jetzt kein war lomar wie lang bin ich schon on guck mal ich bin
doch erst fast zwei stunden on
homo system nee dann kommt man selbst auch nicht an wissen wir ja schon wie es
geht das strom messgerät hatte am start ok ok ich ich will nur ich will nur das
intro hören ich ich will nur das intro hören
hallo in diesem video nur ganz kurz hallo in diesem video nur ganz kurz
gezeigt so geil weißt schon genau was sache ist hallo in diesem video ganz
kurz gezeigt hallo in diesem video nur ganz kurz gezeigt wie wir mit unserem
home ist bedingtet auch mit geräten kommen man kommt das nächste stellenanzeigen
video wahrscheinlich nach dem battlefield video also am neunten
jetzt battlefield video und stream und dann wahrscheinlich hier irgendwann so
am wochenende oder so 18 monat dankeschön für haipa
subscription
firefox 89 review ok das muss man sich angucken ich kann mein review selbst ich
habe ihn jetzt eine weile verwendet seit heraus ist also mein review zu firefox
89 ist das neue ui ich zeige es euch mal juckt mich überhaupt net habe ich
überhaupt keine probleme mit
aber warum ich der meinung bin dass firefox die letzten jahre über auch immer
schlechter wird beziehungsweise nicht schlechter man kann schlechter kann man
nicht sagen aber firefox vergisst wer firefox
verwendet firefox ist der browser für die hacker manns ja der mainstream die
0 auf 15 leute verwenden chrome und firefox wird von leuten benutzt die
interessiert sind an von webentwicklung bis add-on customizable browser also die
leute die eigentlich keinen easy mode browser wollen und ich bin der meinung
firefox entwickelt schon die letzten drei vier jahre komplett an ihrer
zielgruppe vorbei
firefox war immer schon der hacker mann browser also vor allem seit chrome
großes ist chrome der mainstream browser und firefox der hacker mann browser und
gerade mit solchen dingern hier wir tun so wir tun so als sind wir in den als
sind wir auf einem tablet packt halt einfach nur ab die müssen die können
nicht mainstream werden wie sollen sie das machen
chrome chrome ist der mainstream browser gerade weil das ding von google ist die
können da nicht dagegen anstinken hat mir auch gesehen
die hatten eine ganz gute verbreitung bevor chrome rausgekommen ist aber die
waren die waren weit davon entfernt quasi da irgendwie 90 prozent oder so zu
haben auch davor schon die waren nur ganz gut dabei und ich weiß nicht was sie
jetzt für einen anteil haben die müssen gucken wer ist ihre zielgruppe und meiner
mein nach ist die firefox zielgruppe eben technik interessierte die mit ihrem
browser dinger machen wollen die man so vielleicht im chrome nicht machen kann
dürfen feature requests ins repo vom speedchamp gemacht werden kannst du
machen aber ich weiß nicht ob wir es machen aber du kannst so machen ja hast
du schon über die battle field 6 liegs gesprochen
ja ich habe dazu gesagt dass ich dazu nichts sagen darf weil ich so
unterschrieben habe
ok wir gucken uns mal kurz an was der zum firefox 89 zu sagen hat ich gehe mal
voraus dass ich das ähnlich ich finde es gar nicht so schlecht das ist doch kaum
es ist doch gar kein so großen unterschied das einzige was ich ein
bisschen nervig finde ist das mache ich mal kurz das ist hier oben jetzt so
also ich will es ausblenden ok dass es hier oben jetzt so fett ist das nervt
mich ein bisschen das ist eindeutig größer aber auch nicht viel größer
weiß nicht also aber ansonsten hat sich doch kaum was getan was hältst du vom
opera gx habe ich mir ausprobiert
habe ich mir ausprobiert ja ich auch nicht sehe ich ganz genau so sehe ich
genauso ich mag meistens ui changes auch nicht es sei denn ich sage ich will
dass das anders wird aber dass die dann dass der hersteller gleichermaßen sagt
ja wir machen es dann auch so wie du haben willst kommt eigentlich nie schon
mal von brave gehört ja aber wüsste ich jetzt auch nicht warum ich das nehmen
sollte also auf dem desktop auf dem smartphone
mag das anders aussehen wobei auch da gibt es ja auch andere browser mit
eingebautem add filter und sowas aber nicht unbedingt
also ich benutze auf android benutze ich den hier als browser
bromide
es ist ein chrome das ist ein chrome entguggelt und mit blocker drinnen
den finde ich eigentlich ganz nice
ich meine das logo sieht halt richtig pence champion aus sondern es hat
irgendwie ein dreijähriger in gimp gemacht wahrscheinlich auch noch
hier ich weiß, dass das wahrscheinlich die wichtigste Sache ist, dass die Leute
sich darüber konfrontieren, insbesondere diejenigen, die einen kleineren Monitor haben
ich glaube ich bin ein bisschen glücklich, einen 27-Inch-Full-HD-Monitor zu haben
aber sogar auf so etwas größeres wie diesen ist das noch bemerkbarer
ja ich verstehe auch nicht warum man das größer macht warum geht das jetzt mal
ich habe eine echt echt blöde frage warum hat von den browser herstellern
ist noch keiner auf die idee gekommen zu sein
wir versuchen es hier oben mal irgendwie ein bisschen kleiner zu machen ich meine
ich muss auch sagen, sogar in chrome ist mir das ganze schon so groß
warum warum kann man nicht zum beispiel sagen
nehmen wir jetzt mal den firefox hier ich mache noch mal kurz die
die bookmarks, okay lassen wir es mal so
warum kann man nicht zum beispiel sagen man macht die adressleiste hier oben rein
weil die adressleiste ist ja die muss ja nicht so lang sein
man könnte ohne probleme die adressleiste hier oben rein machen
und expandieren wenn man reinklickt
zum beispiel ja frag mich warum das noch keiner warum da noch keiner
ein bisschen mit experimentiert hat weil umso mehr
vertikalen screen
screen space man spart umso besser
safari macht das ja gut eins muss man sagen apple
ist was so designsachen angeht oftmals gar nicht verkehrt apple hat aber auch
das problem wenn es halt zackt dann ziehen sie es trotzdem durch
das wäre zum beispiel so ein ding das verstehe ich nicht das könnte man das
könnte man auf jeden fall machen auch ansonsten könnte man das ganze dynamischer
machen weiß gar nicht kann man mittlerweile die sachen in in
firefox eigentlich gruppieren wenn man sie irgendwie zusammen zieht also man
könnte richtig viele coole sachen machen wo ich mir frag warum macht es
eigentlich keiner
echt nicht echt nicht
macht doch auch wenn mich das ausfaden nervt um ehrlich zu sein
macht doch
so